[ __ ] degli aggiunti ragazze
prevenuti avessero video sono fa vj del
caso vi stesse chiedendo perché io ho i
capelli in questo modo bello perché alla
moda
ho finito già questo video semplicemente
sto facendo la intro alla fine del video
perché questo è un videogioco però cruz
lift che pensavo fosse una roba
tranquilla ma manco per il caso io vi
lascio al video anche se è una cosa un
po strana perché state per vedere cose
strane niente ragazzi preparate i pop
corn e buona visione
credetemi che ce ne sarà bisogno da chio
ragazzi proprio quella roba con locus
trip se riesco a farla perfetto giorno e
nemmeno la mia classe lunedì credo che
sia un horror ragazzi me lo suggerisce
la scritta iniziale non ne sono
convintissimo però è presto spese
interrotte dai partiamo questa roba
quindi farli di tua madre oh cazzo
cos'è e figo oddio no vabbè ma io io mi
comando con la torta posso muovermi
posso muovermi no posso darmi la torcia
nei maroni però fantastico questo la cia
c'è il figo ma sii serio
ragazzi è bruttissimo a parte della roba
che volteggia in aria non ho capito che
cos'è con bolle belle scale complimenti
è molto tranquilla zona
ciao medica che che cosa di merda che
fate l'altro o lo zio bobby ragazzi
perché c'è zio bobby che sto suonando il
pianoforte che cosa nicchia studio york
io devo proprio continuare a fissarti
mentre stai suonando no perché sono i di
merda non è uno scherzo automotive kat
von d io ti conosco se irrascibile non
ti incazzare che stavo scherzando
[Musica]
chi ha chiuso zio bobby t'ammazzo
ricordare che sono le due di notte sta
giocando sta roba ed è bruttissimo di
andare a che mario era più le odio le
bambine che cantano degli horror di che
si credono celine dion o beyoncé non è
più se quella non è beyoncé quella
libertà non era proprio dai cazzo proci
secci somigliava io mi fai una cortesia
mandi a [ __ ] e facendo ho detto sta
gente non il tavolo
ciao e voi chi ti tagli capelli non
perché sei a posto
però posso usarti come sfera di
cristallo 6 vogliono non solo decido ha
visto si occupino qualcuno a una
soluzione per un tavolo che ha delle
convulsioni ragazze la cosa più orribile
preceduto serve lavezzi però io sono di
qua guardami guardami sono qui che cazzo
guardi da sei una che la finale in fi
stavo per dire che eri una bella [ __ ] ma
stavo scherzando quando ci sono le belle
gnocche ma che sotto ci hanno il
mandrillo tutta un'altra storia li
ragazzi non sia una bella gnocca oppure
c'è il mandrillo non lo sapremo mai
legato che c'era una tizia prima molto
più corrotta di quanto pensato
c'è una porta di mi scusi signora morta
mi scusi signor satana è un grosso lo sa
usa la crema solare lei no non la
capiscono tia che parla mi senta se si
leva dai [ __ ] giuro che le presento
una tizia che conosco io
se solo se si leva dai [ __ ] per me e
qualche caso mai ci ho messo tre secondi
ascolta si sa se un tizio che ti vuole
riuscito io no io no perché so chi sei
in realtà però lui non lo sanno solo
dire che pensa che sei [ __ ] e un bel
culo
stavo scherzando mi chiama anche un
complimento interroghiamo programma per
presentarmi il leone cane fifone non è
così vero
le mie c'è la bambina di the ring mi
esce gesù qualcuno che mi dice che cazzo
devo fare che cos'è oddio ce lo slang
non è tanto il problema della
televisione più cantore ci sono delle
bolle che volteggiano c'è anche una
tizia che volteggia nuda tra l'altro più
tizie nude dante che è un'orgia se
troppo magre però è sì no no no non ci
sto toccando la pace che sono sul
braccio lungo
non ve lo sveglio il cazzo dici adesso
addio se va bene però si possono andare
al bagno
sto scherzando però non ti levi
incazzare ogni volta perché ogni volta
che faccio una proposta c'è del fumo
chiamati i pompieri non chiamate un
cazzo la tramigna un salto figo mi fa
piacere ricevere queste visite
[ __ ] assistenti zio fester dove mi
dove è andato mi sa spiegare chimiche
appena spuntato dalla finestra no
[Musica]
un po d'olio alle porte ragazze problema
è che io sono fermo qui non mi posso
muovere c'è stato
ciao stantio facebook c'è lo zio pensa è
sparito di nuovo ragazzo non c'è più non
c'è mi prende per il culo zio fester non
ama me la faccia player e gas e
tranquilli tranquillissimi c'è proprio
calma somigli mondo a biancaneve sai
sono che hai un po più di tette il che è
positivo
io andrei svab è comunque piacere fa vj
nel caso vi vorresti fare le
presentazioni
proprio oggi tutti scortesi [ __ ] a
bianca ne fece il televisore accertate
canicani anni tutti samara
[Musica]
ma serio va bè ragazzi
questo era e che cazzo appena giocato
non lo so non voglio saperlo non mi
interessa a me rimasto qui zio fester
che se n'è andato subito paura cristiana
allora ragazzi che un crudo che
l'episodio è stato figo ma molto di più
di quanto pensassi miei capelli lo
testimoniano quindi ragazzi spero che vi
sia piaciuto un po di cioni super zio
fester perché zio fester a quanto pare
merita però che vi sia piaciuto come
sento ragazzi se vi è piaciuto questo
momento è un mi piace anche a voce di
facebook che come nei video tratta di
iscrizione travestiti sky fa ci davano
posso video ricordate questo video vi
insegna che se vedete una bella donna
potrebbe nascondere mandrillo le ragazze